What are your teachings, articles you say that radiation will shrink tumors, but doesn't actually kill cancer since it doesn't kill the stem cells.
So let's clarify that. Well, it will kill cancer. So the only way you could shrink a tumor is by killing the cancer.
Is it going to ultimately solve the person's problem if that's the only thing that they did? No, nor will chemo because chemo and radiation don't kill cancer stem cells.
Well, radiation would kill cancer stem cells if they're right at the area that you're radiating because it'll kill everything.
But cancer stem cells are all over your body and trying to set up home and raise a family. So you have to be doing other things too, which you are.
Which even a lot of people that aren't even quote unquote doing alternatives things are their body is trying to kill cancer stem cells.
But you can't expect radiation and chemo to kill cancer stem cells if anybody said that if they dare for the purpose of killing cancer stem cells.
They're lying to you because it's just not true. It doesn't.
So you have to do other things to kill the stem cells.
I was recently.
I was told recently by an oncologist, though that radiation does completely kill stem cells and so is active cure instantly.
Well, yeah, if you if you hit the whatever cells you hit with radiation, they'll kill them whether they're your normal healthy cells, whether they're cancer cells or whether they're cancer stem cells or other stem cells in your body, it'll kill anything that you're pointing it to.
But you're only your point you're not doing full body radiation.
You know, if you were going to try to kill all the stem cells in your body with radiation, you would die. I mean, you can't it's impossible without killing the patient.
So for an oncologist to say that.
That's that's really it's very, very incorrect information.
Now, I get she's just trying to say, oh, this is going to cure you, but still, that is just that's not.
That's not honest, either.
I still get why these guys could say anything they don't want. Please allow me.